[Music]
welcome to the sixth annual Halloween
special that we have done every single
year for the past six years this is my
beautiful wife Sam who was really the
inception of this idea six years ago yep
and we've continued to do it every year
and we're getting old like I think
you're the one who's getting old
well you did put cream on my joints
earlier and I liked it and so that's
probably a good sign of my age I think
we're old and we're dying and we're
gonna talk about trick-or-treat today Oh
a young person thing trick-or-treat was
directed by Michael Dougherty or Michael
Dougherty I'm not sure how to say his
name it's Dorothy it's probably might be
Dorothy but he wrote and directed the
film and it's sort of an anthology movie
five different stories you have a couple
that starts out the film a woman in a
robot costume and you have an older man
in a house played by Brian Cox you have
a kind of demented father and his son
Dylan Baker plays the father and then
you have a group of women who are
wandering around the city in search of
men who they refer to as meat we don't
really know why they refer to them as
fresh meat at first then we have some
kids who are taking jack-o'-lanterns to
an old quarry and I'm not exactly sure
what they're doing and all five of these
stories intersect over the course of
Halloween night yep that sounds about
right
that's the movie thank you I should get
an award this has been one of my
favorite Halloween movies for a long
time and for a while it was really
underappreciated not a lot of people
really talked about this movie how did
you first see trick-or-treat you showed
it to me that's true and what were your
initial thoughts on trick-or-treat I
really loved it it was a really good
movie I actually got into it I enjoy the
story usually I spend most of my time
with horror films laughing my way
through them now are you laughing at the
characters because they're stupid or are
you laughing cuz it's just like you
don't really get it like you know stupid
gotcha usually it's because whatever the
characters are doing
stupid or whatever is being directed as
stupid or they're peppering tons of
jump-scares through the movie for
absolutely no reason other than to give
people false jump scares exactly and
this is why I love you because you
understand me I'm so critical of horror
films because I know what they can do
and I to me like a horror film the
depths of emotion you can get out of an
audience from a horror movie is far
greater really than any other genre
because like fear is such a penetrating
emotion yeah and when you get a good
horror movie that understands that but
also knows how to have fun with it like
this one yeah this one definitely has
fun with how to scare people and make
them feel like they're on edge a little
bit
it takes itself seriously which I
actually appreciate I don't feel like a
lot of horror films feel like they
actually try to make a quality product
they just know that if they can get a
couple of jump scares that they've done
their job and they're gonna make money
regardless because you don't need a lot
of money to make a horror film yeah I
love how clever the direction is because
watching the movie multiple times you
can see how the plot intersect some
characters bump into other people and
you realize oh that's the other story
we've already seen in progress and
there's so many ways the plot intersects
like that and we've seen this done in
movies before and oftentimes it's used
as this way of saying like look how
clever we are but it never really feels
like it over States it's welcome it
never feels like it's the director
saying hey look at me I made a really
clever movie I never feel like I'm being
talked down to whenever I watch this
film it's just such a gleefully
entertaining movie and the director
clearly has an affinity for Halloween
he's actually from Ohio like us and he
loves Halloween as a result because here
in Ohio and in the Midwest we get like
the full Halloween experience you know
like the leaves change colors the air
gets colder
there's trick-or-treat sand haunts
everywhere yeah Ohio has tons and tons
of punch houses like more than a lot of
the states around us combined like it
actually pulled up a map of how many
were in Ohio
we had like eight times the amount of
haunted houses in our state then I think
every state surrounding us we hit like
some 90 haunted houses that were
registered and I know there's tons more
that aren't actually registered because
it will have like little pop-up ones
locally and in the cities or at like
farms like almost every big farm around
here does some type of haunted then
thank God because I love it and it's
clear that that inspired him quite a bit
to make this movie I was doing a little
bit of research and recently that the
shout factory blu-ray came out of
brand-new one and there's a great new
documentary on it where he talks about
trying to convince people to let him
make this movie he made a short film an
animated short film called season's
greetings and that was the first
introduction of the Sam character he
recognized that Christmas had a mascot
Santa Claus Easter Bunny
you know Halloween didn't have a mascot
and he wanted to create this character
this little guy Sam as sort of like a
pseudo mascot for Halloween I love that
it's my name yeah that's great that's I
didn't tell her that the first time I
showed her to her so that was kind of
cool it's nice to find out so I was able
to use that short film that he directed
along with some concept art that he
helped get painted and sort of convinced
studio still this movie to be made but
it actually had a really tough time
getting released for whatever reason
after doing really well at festivals and
winning awards Warner Brothers just
pulled it from the schedule like right
before it was supposed to come out and
they never gave an explanation some
people think it could have been because
saw for was about to come out and they
didn't want to have that competition but
that's kind of dumb I mean like usually
when a movie gets pulled from schedule
or push back it's because it isn't
really that good or because the studio
doesn't have confidence in it but this
is like a great movie yeah it's a really
good film so I don't really understand
the reasoning behind pulling it and
let's say it really were fearful of the
soft film taking off the box-office
money and saw for is not good so poor is
not that was a stupid stupid decision
but it languished for a while in
obscurity where it was just not released
and finally they just released it to
Home Media straight to Home Media yeah
so it didn't really get like a full
theatrical release which is why
had never really heard about it because
it was like oh that's a thing and now
I'm like man I wish I really had gotten
to see this in theaters and it's gotten
so popular now Universal does a haunted
house for it
yes I'm wearing the shirt that we
actually got we just went to Universal
Studios for our fourth anniversary and
the trick-or-treat haunted house was
amazing treat house was amazing
I will loved going to the universal
haunted house event because it was so
much more adult than it was there's some
bloody shit there was some really funny
stuff and they were right there's a
disclaimer on the thing on the website
saying not appropriate for young
children and to be mindful of young
children I'm like yeah they're there
right it's very happy I know it was a
bomb to my soul
apparently Akron just opened up their
first r-rated haunted house really yeah
we should go we should apparently
they're allowed to touch you and like
yelling and seeing things at you and oh
I don't know if I like the touchy yeah I
don't know if I want to be touched by
the people in the corners see I don't
whine stuff like that I'm weird that
kind of stuff actually is what gets me
more than what I I don't get scared in
haunted houses I like I said I mean
weird person who sits and lasted things
I was a terrible child who would go
through the haunted houses and whenever
something would happen I would be like
smiling and giggling and like yay this
is so fun this is exciting
so the haunted house actors were like oh
that's her again yeah they can't scare
her you can't you could they couldn't
scare me the only thing that ever worked
was like if they come out right behind
me I was always drawn to frightening
things when I was a kid too all my
favorite stuff was always scary stuff
are you afraid of the dark goosebumps
the x-files all that stuff I always
wanted to see monster movies it's one of
the things I like about trick-or-treat
is that it does feel like it's born of
that love where the frightening and the
horrific you can tell whoever wrote it
actually enjoyed what they were writing
and not just forced to write something
because it would make them a little bit
of money there's an actual joy to
Halloween that they have and it's I
appreciate it because you actually get
to feel like you're watching a Halloween
film kind of like the Halloween
franchise makes you feel like you're
watching a nice dark Halloween film you
get that same feeling from this because
it brings
that spooky creepy howl like haunted
feeling that you get not a lot of films
do that a lot of them are just slasher
films for the sake of killing people and
seeing boobs I agree with you there's
actual passion behind this project you
can tell that he was really trying to
get it made
he wrote a script he liked and he had to
convince people you know it wasn't just
like as you said a paycheck thing for
him he really wanted to get this movie
out there and you can tell in every
frame that there's just more love given
to it than your average horror movie
every shot was thought about like it's
not just a lot of throwaway scenes for
the sake of Oh a just couple of minutes
here a couple minutes here to bridge the
story there's actual like attention to
detail paid in every scene every shot
has thought and I love that he actually
spent his time crafting this and it
shows when somebody puts their heart and
soul and do it you can really tell it's
why you getting really good films like
Steven Spielberg with his films you can
always tell when he's putting his
passion behind it he they're better
films so I'm gonna give you guys a
spoiler warning if you haven't seen
trick-or-treat we're gonna start talking
about some plot details obviously we
both recommend it one of the things I
love about the movie and and the first
time I showed the Sam I could not wait
for her to see it was the werewolf stuff
because you follow these girls and they
so cleverly set them up as the cliched
young girls only after boys all I want
to do is have sex they're wearing sexy
costumes drinking alcohol they're drunk
they're going to some kind of rave or
party or something and all they talk
about is how they need fresh meat and
how it's their first time and little
girl dresses up like Little Red Riding
Hood and they make a joke when they're
in the dressing room like I'll huff and
I'll puff and there are all these little
pieces like that sprinkled throughout
and then you find out that they're
werewolves and they're gonna be mating
and killing men and stuff and it's just
such a great reveal they're literally
ripping their skin off it's one of my
favorite werewolf scenes in any movies
yeah they went back to old-school
werewolf lore where where was shed their
human skin off like goose bumps did that
werewolf skin where skin also playing on
that old horror trophy peeling on the
skin
I appreciated that because also they
killed one of the other characters who
also was doing naughty things on
Halloween yeah it's kind of like a sick
demented haha you get your just reward
thing it was great so it kind of
connects you back to the other stories
when the werewolves transform is that
now the guy who killed his students is
now getting his chest do yes yes and
that crazy guy was played by Dylan Baker
who some of you might remember as dr.
Connors from the first to spider-man
films or should I say spider-man 2 and
spider-man 3 never got to be the lizard
in Sam Raimi's movies this kind of leads
me to something I noticed last night
when I rewatched it I cannot think of a
movie that has more children dying
I actually agree so many children dying
this a lot there's a lot of kids who die
in this film how many kids did he have
in that hole so he had he kills the one
kid there was another kid in there who
had like a clown costume on and there is
another kid early in the movie that had
a clown costume and I'm actually not
sure if it's the same I can't confirm
that then he kills the one kid by
poisoning his candy but it's clear that
he's done it before because the son
later is like cover scary face this time
so the son isn't like surprised by it
this is clearly something that's
happened before also there's a bus
filled with children chained up to seats
who all drown in a flashback sequence
and then later come back as zombies so
that kids right could get killed and the
other stunt that happens for the night
there's a lot of kids who get killed in
this cell yeah and usually Louise don't
touch on that they don't usually go
after kids because it's seen as I guess
crossing the line one of my favorite
characters in the movie is Rondo
yeah she has all these beautiful
pumpkins she's carved I love the actress
she does such a good job I wish I
remembered her name and they're trying
to play a trick on her and she gets back
at them basically and that's one of the
other things about the film that I love
it it is crowd-pleasing
like it sets up these little pieces like
you have the bus driver who agreed to
kill all those kids who later ends up
being the old
in the house and the zombie kids show up
at his door you know and then Rhonda
gets her just do and the zombie kids
attack the kids and it's just a really
crowd-pleasing movie in that aspect
where it's kind of about righting the
wrongs on Halloween because that's what
the Sam character does you know he walks
around and looks for people who are
breaking the Halloween rules it kills
them the only death that kind of almost
doesn't make sense is the robot
character the woman's beginning except
for that she blew out the
jack-o'-lantern and she's like I hate
Halloween
yeah then he's like you actually hear a
little a little like a little boy voice
underneath the scarf or sever or the
knapsack which I've always loved I love
that I'll tell you the deaths that don't
really make sense to me and it's really
my only real issue with the film the
backstory with the school bus is told
through a narration of a little girl and
she's basically saying that all of the
parents in the neighborhood agreed that
they don't want their kids anymore
because their kids aren't like the other
kids I'm like come on there were like 10
kids on that bus you're really gonna say
all those parents got together and were
like I hate my children yeah I hate my
kids too hey let's pay the bus driver to
murder him okay cool like it just to me
that was a little far-fetched it works
in there in a sense that it's an urban
legend yeah we don't know if that was
the actual story that it was never
confirmed if that was the case obviously
the bus went off into the quarry because
the kids come back out and they go after
the bus driver so we're gonna assume
it's probably the correct story yeah but
there might have been more to it maybe
he just decided to do it without being
the parents paying for it see I would
have liked that better it works as an
urban legend
the town might say but then it's sort of
proven true and so I was kind of like
yeah that's really my only if the
portion of the film I think that it's
such a gorgeously shot extremely well
lit the colors in the movie the oranges
and the yellows the design of Sam so
unique by the way is right there and
he's been there for a long time every
time I've come
I love them I want to get the big mask I
really like I said I really enjoy this
film I would highly recommend it to
anybody to watch it and sit down and
enjoy a nice Halloween to Philip it's
one of those ones where I do try to
weight talk to where to watch it though
it's not one of those I'm gonna watch it
there all the rest of the year I gotta
try to watch it at Halloween time
because it feels better to watch it at
Halloween time and every time I watch it
all I want to do is turn our front yard
into like a haunted horror festival and
I'm like I need to sit down and do some
serious budget and so one year I can
actually pull it off cuz I'll probably
it's a hire whole bunch people to help
me to pull off turn in our front yard
into a haunted house that would be
pretty awesome and I want to do it I
will help you with that I also love to
watch it every Halloween this and John
Carpenter's first Halloween film have
become staples for my Halloween every
single year it's a must watch I really
truly recommend this movie if you're
fans of the holiday or if you're just
fans of a good fun time I'm gonna give
trick or treat and a I would also agree
a is probably else what I would give it
only because I wouldn't give it an A+
only because one or two story elements
don't quite actually work and once you
watch it a few times you notice it a
little bit more but that's about it yeah
I mean in regards to sitting down and
actually crafting this on a blank screen
it's really impressive yeah yeah whole
little thing cuz I mean I've always
thought about trying to write like an
anthology like this and it's crazy
because you kind of have to like make a
timeline first of what actually happened
and then you can take all those pieces
and shuffle them around in different
ways and they intersect really well and
a lot of times with anthologies there's
always that moment where you're like
that didn't quite line up the timeline
watching it again last night there there
isn't a moment that doesn't feel like it
doesn't flow ya know it all connects
very well like I said it's just one or
two little story omits @dr quite drive
thank you very much my beautiful wife
Sam for joining me and I look forward to
more reviews we're gonna do a few more
for you guys this October we got a bunch
of plans it's gonna be fun so has some
other people guest-starring I might not
be in all of the reviews but we'll have
some fun people to replace me for sure
yep alright well guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck behind
[Music]